bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france quel regard
portez-vous aujourd'hui sur la gestion
de la crise sanitaire en termes
d'équipement écoutez en ce qui concerne
en tout cas les médicaments qui est mon
domaine de connaissance il n'y a pas eu
vraiment de gros problèmes je pense que
les choses se sont bien passées même si
c'était évidemment difficile les
professionnels de santé que ça soit les
pharmaciens d'officine les industries
telles les gros titres
la petite heure ont fait beaucoup
d'efforts pour réussir à donner aux
patients leur traitement et en
particulier dans le domaine du coc vide
vous avez beaucoup de produits qu'on
était très consommée pendant cette
période en particulier hydroxyde n'est
pas uniquement par exemple les curares
qui ont vu leur consommation multipliée
par dix quasiment évidemment il a fallu
gérer cette crise avec une cellule de
clé spéciale où les pharmaciens
hospitaliers où on joue un rôle majeur
quand vous entendez aujourd'hui emmanuel
macron affirmé que la france n'a jamais
connu de rupture dans
l'approvisionnement de masques quelle
est votre réaction
écoutez moi sur les masques je ne
connais pas vraiment le problème donc je
ne peux pas porter de jugement
je sais que ça a été surtout très
compliquée sur le plan de la
communication
ce que les pharmaciens d'officine ont eu
des des contre ordres à plusieurs
reprises sur ce qu'il fallait faire
donc je peux pas vous dire grand chose
sur le sujet là parce qu'il ya eu
effectivement cet imbroglio dans les
pharmacies au début on le rappelle la
vente des masques
ils étaient interdites au public réservé
au personnel soignant finalement la
vente a été autorisé pour les masques
issues de l'importation à partir du 23
mars en éléments qu'il y aura une
majorité des français comment expliquer
cette absence de clarification de la
part de l'état encore aujourd'hui selon
vous j'ai pas vraiment d'explication
encore une fois je ne suis pas
spécialiste du problème des masses je
sais simplement que les masques au
départ
louis - considère ce n'était pas
indispensable et je pense que le
gouvernement a suivi cette
recommandation
et puis ensuite ça a été différent par
la suite donc c'est vrai que c'était un
peu compliqué en termes de communication
comment se porte aujourd'hui
plus généralement les stocks des
pharmacies pour l'instant les stocks
sont internes
mika mansour sont correctement il n'y a
pas de souci particulier quand ils foyer
eu des tortures sur certains produits
par exemple sur le paracétamol il ya eu
beaucoup d'achats camp était fait des
achats de précaution par les patients ce
qui ont fait que il ya eu des tensions
d'approvisionnement par exemple sur la
su également il ya eu le même type de
problème mais globalement encore une
fois les stocks ont été correct mais
malgré tout on l'a entendu on a beaucoup
parlé quelques baigneurs et comment
faire à la verte pour que ce genre de
situation ne se reproduise plus alors il
faut bien distinguer ce qui concerne la
période du coc u19 qui est quand même
tout à fait exceptionnelle et sur lequel
il va falloir réfléchir en terme de
préparation d'un plan de crise qui
n'existe pas aujourd'hui
à mon avis il faudrait vraiment
réfléchir à une façon d'attaquer des
crises futures mais donc dans l'autre
côté bien avant la crise du que vides
l'académie de pharmacie avait déjà
souligné depuis plusieurs années le
problème des ruptures
d'approvisionnement en médicaments et
qui n'ont rien à voir avec problèmes du
quotidien
là il va falloir réellement travaillé
sur ce sujet et je pense que les allées
les politiques sont prêts aujourd'hui à
le faire à plusieurs niveaux parce que
les ruptures de stock sont dus à
beaucoup de beaucoup de cause en
particulier mais pas uniquement ou fait
que ces produits sont produits en chine
où on en ce qui concerne les matières
premières est en partie également en
dehors de l'europe pour les produits
finis donc c'est une des causes
évidentes de ces ruptures il va falloir
travailler sur ce sujet les relocaliser
en europe
un certain nombre de productions
mais ce n'est pas la seule cause il ya
également d'autres causes qui sont tout
aussi importants et qui va falloir
travailler il faut mettre un doigt
aujourd'hui assez dépendance de
l'étranger dès lors qu'il s'agit de la
santé est ce que c'est possible oui
c'est tout à fait possible évidemment il
ya eu un certain nombre d'entreprises
qui ont relocalisé une partie de leur
production
et c'est un mouvement général qui soit
en europe ou aux états unis d'ailleurs
donc vous puisse est possible mais il va
falloir qu'on est les conditions
favorables pour le faire les conditions
d'abord économique parce qu'en général
sur des produits anciens et pas chers
qui sont en rupture et c'est la raison
pour laquelle il aurait été délocalisée
très souvent donc il faudra
effectivement réexaminer les conditions
économiques mais également les
conditions d'environnement puisque c'est
parti en inde et en chine souvent
pendant environnementale donc il va
falloir qu'on retravaille également là
dessus trouvez les ans et des propres
compatible avec la réglementation sur
l'environnement
docly a également bien sûr des aspects
réglementaires des aspects légaux
tout ça doit être retravaillé pour
permettre une roulotte quand
localisation en europe
merci beaucoup d'avoir pris le temps de
répondre à nos questions bruno bonnement
je rappelle que vous êtes membre de
l'académie nationale de pharmacie